reneeze Federal Minister for Family
Affairs and Commissioner for integration
have invited 130 local politicians to
discuss the threat of right-wing
extremism among the guests is the mayor
of hidin L a town in eastern Germany the
summer right-wing extremists committed
xenophobic attacks in his community over
the course of several days Ezard em up
is sin hide this mob isn't on the
streets of hype now at the moment but of
course it has a permanent presence on
social media dominant present on every
movement of refugees is commented on in
a hateful and inhumane way mention for
often refugee accommodations have been
under attack nearly every day across
Germany right-wing extremists and other
xenophobes make constant calls to harass
migrants politicians no longer just want
to stand by and watch those few Muslims
dead we have to stand up to this
harassment understood we support the
mayors and the volunteers very
specifically on location with our
program live democracy which includes
for example mobile counselling teams
that go to effect in places and give
help and advice if there are problems
Venice problem agita the German
government has now increased funding for
the live democracy program to about 50
million euros which also funds
nationwide democracy centers hi dena
mayor Jurgen Oh Pete says help is
desperately needed